hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamra Jessa I am gonna be
telling you my Oscar picks for this year
and I'm excited to talk about it I did
this last year and I haven't seen barely
any of the film's this year I had seen
more than half which is very exciting
Thank You Tamra Josiah Thank You channel
awesome thank you I accept this award I
went on a movie watching spree in the
last few days and I caught up except for
all the money in the world and Molly's
game those are the two films I didn't
see I'm also not going to be doing
documentaries or foreign films I just
didn't have a time but everything else
I'm gonna be talking about so I'm very
excited looking to do it right yes good
and the nominees for visual effects are
blade 2049 guardians the galaxy vol 2
console I'm in Star Wars the last Jedi
warrant for the Planet of the Apes it's
a bit unfair because I liked a lot of
these films but this is so bias to me
anything with Star Wars in it I just
want Star Wars to win it wasn't
nominated for very much I'll sound of
course is John Williams
I've watched Star Wars when Blade Runner
may win I really hope Kong Skull Islands
and war for the Planet of the Apes don't
win I don't know why they were fine
films honestly better than I thought
they were going to be they don't want
them to win
costume design pretty sure the only one
that has Beauty and the Beast in it
beauty on the beats darkest hour
Fandral Fred the shape of water Victoria
and Abdul I really loved Victoria and
Abdul I did I watched it and it's only
nominated for costume and makeup and I
was like oh my god I have to sit I'm
just gonna watch the first half hour of
this just so I get like the gist of how
it looks and I ended up watching the
whole thing and it was delightful so I'm
gonna almost like that makeup in hair oh
I'll just take that thank you
the darkest hour Victoria in Abdul and
wonder I just thought the darkest hour
was so boring honestly as a film gary
oldman was incredible in the darkest
hour but I don't know I just felt as
alluring I want Victoria Abdul to win
again I think darkest hour will win and
rightfully so it's it was really well
done he looked amazing and the nominees
for original song go to my favorite from
Adobe
from coca dynami stand up or something
for marshal god I love that movie this
is me the greatest showman I thought the
song was cool I want Mighty River Who am
I bound to win I think Coco will win and
I'd be very pleased if either of them
did and the nominees for Original Score
are dunder phantom thread they shake
water Star Wars the last Jedi free
billboards out there I don't even have
to finish it Star Wars I want Star Wars
to win and the category I care the least
about production design maybe the beats
later 20 49 darkest hour Dunkirk the
shake of water how funny would it be a
Beauty and the Beast one anything
I think Blade Runner should win and
honestly it's either gonna be that or
the shape of water I think for
production designer another category I
care very little about sound mixing
Peggy driver Playboy 49 Dunkirk shaken
water start was the last time I think
anything would sound Star Wars should
win John Williams is a hero and a saint
and he should be praised yes sound
editing 85 29 Dunkirk she quadrants are
where Star Wars again Star Wars should
win both the same same exact thing in my
mind film editing baby driver Dunkirk I
told you we should have water and three
billboard outside I think Missouri
honestly I think the baby driver should
witness baby driver is on my top 10
favorite movies list was baby river oh
yeah baby driver wasn't sound out of ink
oh and sound mixing I just completely
looked over that awesome Best live
action short film to call elementary 11
o'clock beside a child and once we woke
all of us I was in a theater watching
the short film short live-action films
and the first one started and it was
about a shooting in a school and just
the entire audience just groaned from
like uncomfortableness to something
that's in the news so much just the
uncomfortableness that that made me feel
and it was it was beautifully done I
think that should win what I think will
win is the silent child which is also
really beautiful
honestly the pics were amazing and it
was really nice they had the 11 o'clock
in there for just like a just a small
smidgen of comedy cinematography
playground 20:49
the Drakh is our Dunkirk my bound to
shake the water cinematography I think
should be Blade Runner and I think it's
going to be Dunkirk original screenplay
the big sick get out
laboured the shape of water three
billboard outside I think Missouri I
think it should go to get out I think it
might go to labored adapted screenplay
combining it disaster artist Logan
Molly's game and my bound again I didn't
see Molly's game
I can't speak on that but I will say
that the others in this list are
incredible mud bound was amazing it's on
Netflix which is another reason that I
like it so much I'm all about Netflix
just taking over the industry Logan was
incredible and I would love to see Logan
take home an Oscar calling by your name
was beautiful and heartbreaking disaster
artist was funny hmm
I won't mud bound to win I think it's
gonna go to call me by your name also
it'd be hilarious if the disaster artist
won an Oscar but I don't I think there's
better in the category animated shorts
dear basketball darn partying blue
negative space revolting rhymes the
first one dear basketball was about Kobe
Bryant garden party was this weird one
about frogs and a dead body killer just
so interesting Lou though I think is
going to win its Pixar it's really sweet
it's about bullying and redemption of a
bully in a good way I think Lou is going
to win animated feature boss baby the
breadwinner cocoa for the dance bloody
Vincent this is such an odd list to me
honestly the boss baby I'm sorry
in what world is the boss baby a best
animated feature film did they not see
Captain Underpants did they not see any
other animated film this year except for
the emoji movie like boss baby and emoji
movie could be like intermixed together
I just don't understand that breadwinner
is an important tale to tell but it is
so sad it's also on Netflix I would
recommend watching it it's a heavy one
Coco I love start-to-finish I loved
everything about it for today I was cute
loving Vincent was difficult for me to
get through amazing and very impressive
but after that wears off it's just kind
of like I want Coco to win and I think
Coco will win if boss baby comes out of
anyone's lips that night I will be very
disappointed and directors Dunkirk get
out laboured fancy Fred
the Sheikh water I think Guillermo del
Toro should win it and I think he will
win it I would love to see Jordan Peele
win as well and Greta Gerwig I would
that's supporting actress mary j blige
mud bound Allison Janney hi Tanya
Lesley Manville Fenton thread Laurie
Metcalf Lady Bird take you Spencer
there's no water Laurie Metcalf is
probably going to win it I'd love to see
mary j blige win it she was so
unexpected for me but honestly this list
is just full of women that I would just
be joy joy filled to see win supporting
actor Willem Dafoe the floor project
literally only to think about in my
opinion what do I open read the words
like he was already Richard Jenkins and
shake water Christopher Plummer all the
money the world Sam Rockwell three
billboard that I got a misery again I
didn't see all the money in the world so
I can't talk about Christopher Plummer I
would love to see Richard Jenkins win
for the shape of water lead actress
Sammy Hawkins the shake of water Fred
suburban three billboards like Missouri
Margot Bobby I told you I don't have a
sorority bro man Lady Bird I'm so sorry
here told me to and Meryl Streep the
post I love Meryl but she's not in this
running for me I also thought Frances
McDormand was incredible in three
billboards she was by far my favorite
part Sally Hopkins in the shape of water
she just seems like that type of person
that you could just like have a sweet
ass conversation with and she'll just
smile that she would make you feel like
everything's gonna be okay you know what
I mean so I think Sally is my choice
lead actor do you shall become fireman
Dan Taylor smitten bread Daniel Kelly
I'm selling Saxon I can't Daniel Daniel
get up go meet darkest hour until
watchin from a J's realize where I want
Denzel Washington to win him honestly I
want him to finally get this goddamn
Oscar I want him to win it if it went to
Daniel forget out I would be also very
excited I think it's gonna go to Gary
Oldman for darkest hour but she was so
good it's just such a boring movie
alright where's your best picture
call me by your name darkest hour
Dunkirk
get out Lady Bird phantom thread the
post the shape of water and three
billboards outside Epping Missouri there
are so many good films on this list call
me by your name was beautiful and an
important story and really honestly just
made me want to live with his parents
because they were cool as hell darkest
hour and my opinion was the weakest for
me I still know why it's nominated for
all these awards and I do think that it
will take something home the Emmys this
year what are we even doing here Tamra
at the Oscars this year darkest hour
again important story to tell just
boring for me done
jerk so similar to the darkest hours
more action of course very very sad and
beautiful and importance and just I
could have done without probably not my
kind of film I don't think Lady Bird I
thoroughly enjoyed I thought it was
amazing and I cried and it was just it
was super lovely phantom thread gorgeous
and boring the post well acted in boring
three billboards outside Epping Missouri
stressful important not my choice for
Best Picture overall I think it's got to
be get out or the shape of water that's
what I want to win I have a feeling the
shape of water is going to win it's just
nominated for everything and that's
exciting it's super fun um I do know so
many people who didn't love it so I
would be interested to see what you guys
think what you guys thoughts tell me
what your picks are and watch with me
I'm gonna try to do an Oscar vlog thank
you so much for watching
fingers crossed I would just like to say
that I can't believe I was nominated for
Best hyper fangirl
[Music]